you get a short notice call and that's
how you get into the ufc like very
rarely do guys ever get into the ufc by
you know like hey here's an eight-week
camp and here's your first date in the
ufc that's not how it works but like
someone pulls out
and then and then so actually i fought
in phoenix
a week before my ufc debut so i fought
on a
friday and then i i won that fight as
i'm taking off my hand wraps
uh someone from the commission is like
hey man like
ufc is on the phone they're like hey can
you fight next week and i'm like
i guess i'm not partying tonight but
yeah i mean i'll definitely
you know i'll definitely do that was
that an exciting call to get oh dude it
was so exciting man
so exciting like uh was that like the
best was that like the call
it was the call bro it was a call and
like uh
yeah bro for whatever reason man like uh
i get really pumped like knowing that i
made my loved ones like really proud
yeah you know uh and i remember like
it's one of my favorite parts like when
i do the visualizations i do a lot of
visualizations of like what happens
after the fight too because it really
motivates me you know and it makes me
feel nice like i'll imagine like face
time in my family
and my girlfriend and you know and like
you know they're super pumped for me and
stuff so
that's what that was for me is it was i
remember i was on the phone with my
sister and for what
for whatever reason like it was my
sister but i was i like called my sister
and i was like hey like i did it like
they want me
you know next week and then i was like
yeah and then i remember talking to
christian and i was like
i was like watching this film because i
was like [ __ ] it if i get a contract i
don't care how tough the guy is i don't
care if he beats my ass as long as i get
a contract and i watch the guy this is
when you know my confidence wasn't like
where it is now and i was like oh [ __ ] i
think i'm really going to beat this guy
like it was like some surprise you know
christian was like
yeah dude what like they're calling you
for a reason dumbass like
oh so you think they called you think
they thought you would beat the guy
i don't know if they did or not but that
dude fought on the contender series
uh and they just needed like a
replacement fight like they have to put
a certain amount of fights
to fill their tv slot or whatever and
yeah that's how you get signed to the
ufc pretty much is like some short
notice like that
yeah it was cool dude i remember i
remember the time
i got a text from joe rogan to come be
on his podcast and that was
that was that for me nice it was like
the best thing like
i'd assure you i'm being like what what
am i going to do
i brought him a bag of oranges dude i
didn't know what to do
people said he likes like diet or
something so i [ __ ] got a bag
diet so i bought him like a um
bag of clementines and brought him over
there
how'd it go it went fine was it scary
it was so scary really it was like dude
honestly i think going in
that would almost be like going and
being in a in a fight man
yeah it was so scary were you like were
you more like uh were you like don't
[ __ ] this up
type of i was just scared it was like
um i knew other people that had been on
it like
famous people educators
like that yeah really yeah uh
i don't know joe doesn't care if you
like say that you're going to be on a
show either right
uh-uh yeah i'm going on a show last week
yeah no way bro
bro so i got a text from him and our
instagram message i know bro and it was
it just came randomly from him yeah yeah
wow and i know what i'm talking about
yeah dude i was like yes you text me you
know like i was super pumped but i was
like
uh in my head though i'm just like yeah
man there's [ __ ] like
real legit people you know yeah like
smart
you know like legit people that are like
that foes on there they get a [ __ ]
alien on their last week yeah they're
like changing the world and [ __ ]
yeah dude it was so much fun and then
also i think for you to be able to go in
there and talk to a guy like
that just knows so much about like what
you guys
do and um yeah that's awesome
yeah i think i was just i i'm
intimidated by joe
as a person and it's nothing he does
it's just who kind of who i am and where
where i kind of come into hum like
relationships at it sometimes i think
but um so i think i was probably kind of
nervous about that maybe
um what else do you still feel that way
like even if i went back or you still i
would feel that way yeah
yeah i think some things make me feel a
little bit
it was live then also oh yeah live feels
very nervous
you know like i wish you guys at least
that's what i feel bad for you guys like
tim this is live like
if you [ __ ] hit you can't ask him to
edit it
like hey can you just edit this so it
just looks like a square dance between
two people
um that's but uh that's awesome man
i feel like in like being alive that's
like the call to get
like getting to go there and you get to
go to austin too yeah and see the new
place that's [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah hope you enjoyed that
video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one